bonjour à vous henri sterdyniak alors
que pensez-vous de cette initiative de
l'union européenne j'enchaîne les gens
ce n'était pas tragique chez la mode
actuellement le demander aux plus riches
et aux grandes entreprises de payer
normalement leurs impôts d'éviter
l'optimisation fiscale la mode
maintenant c'est d'organiser des
téléthons c'est à dire des appels à la
charité
aussi quand même étrange plus on a
besoin comme ça de faire appel à la
charité pour récupérer de l'argent pour
une tâche totalement indispensables
comme la recherche médicale ou la
recherche en matière de vaccins pourquoi
pas c'est la mode
un téléthon mondial vous l'avait bien
dit qui s'appuie sur une aide demandée
notamment à des philanthropes
on sait que l'union européenne compte
sur la fondation de bill et melinda
gates en revanche l'aide directe du
président américain donald trump ce
n'est pas certain là encore ça pose
aussi un une question s'agissant de
l'indépendance en finalement d'un
bruxelles pas la question c'est que d'un
côté trump ne peut plus soutenir l'om et
ses troupes un déficit de ce point de
vue donc va falloir que les pays
européens et les pays asiatiques
effectivement finance finance
l' oms et puis d'autre part se retrouve
dans une situation un peu paradoxale
puisque naturellement on va demander à
des millionnaires des milliardaires te
2-2 de payer pour ce téléthon est
naturellement bat pour eux ça va être
une opération un peu un publicitaire
comme on l'a vu avec avec notre dame
voilà pour espérer que les plus riches
les comptes d'entreprises vont
effectivement donné quelques quelques
millions et puis ça va les exonérer en
quelque sorte de l'effort qui est
nécessaire en matière de en matière de
fiscalité un l'europe n'aurait l'europe
et les pays européens n'ont pas besoin
en principe de faire appel à la charité
pour récupérer cette gen 2 5 milliards à
la recherche scientifique est quelque
chose qu'il faut soutenir de façon
permanente le fait est que durant ces
dernières années il ya eu des politiques
d'austérité dans les pays européens en
raison de la pression de bruxelles pour
réduire les dépenses publiques et
naturellement c'est austérité ça a pesé
sur les hôpitaux sa pesée comme on l'a
vu sur la recherche médicale on a eu des
exemples de laboratoire ont été privés
de de crédit alors qu'il travaillait sur
le corps n'a vu sur le sur les
coronavirus on leur disait ben c'est pas
d'actualité et que ce qui est important
c'est quand même d'avoir une politique
de recherche de long terme financé par
des impôts et avoir des comptes
d'entreprises et des milliardaires qui
payent ce qui dois-je l'union européenne
qui a quand même pas mal engagée de 2
millions 1 pourra
pour la recherche on sait que s'agissant
du vaccin contre locaux vides 19 la
compétition elle est rude puisqu'il ya
des recherches en cours en chine aux
états unis
finalement dans tout ça on a
l'impression qu'il ya une absence de
coopération internationale est ce que
c'est un avantage de l'union européenne
il ya de nombreux laboratoires qui
cherche il ya une collaboration qui est
sans doute difficile à organiser entre
les laboratoires
il faut voir aussi que une grande partie
de la recherche est foncièrement
décentralisée c'est-à-dire basque chacun
chaque laboratoire suisse a beast chacun
son idée le grande partie du travail ça
consiste à tester sur le vin sur le le
virus
un certain nombre de médicaments de
produits qui existent déjà donc il ya
quand même d'accord au niveau des
laboratoires up pour dire ma chacun suit
tel ou tel telle ou telle piste
ce qui est important c'est effectivement
ce qu'on peut regretter d'abord c'est
qu' il n'y a pas plus de laboratoires
qui étant assez travaillé sur cette
piste il faut être conscient du fait que
l'humanité dans les années à venir pour
un risque important c'est qu'il y ait de
plus en plus de pandémie parce que l'on
abîme la nature masculin on défriche les
forêts parce que il ya un réchauffement
climatique d'autres ça doit être un
travail de longue haleine
et puis voilà les laboratoires chacun
cherche de son côté faut espérer que
hans et laboratoire va tromper c'est pas
évident jusqu'à présent on n'a jamais
réussi à avoir de vaccin contre ce genre
de ce genre de virus et donc recherché
mais il n'est pas sûr que même en
mettant de l'argent aux troubles mais il
ya un véritable enjeu économique dans la
recherche de 500 précisément ils
occupent les enjeux économiques est
relativement limité si vous il est tout
à fait primordiale pour nous
pour l'humanité effectivement de trouver
un axe à ça permettra effectivement de
mettre fin à rodez confinement ça m ça
permettra de mettre fin à la situation
sociale d'isolement où nous sommes
le fait de savoir quel laboratoire va
trouver dans quel pays c'est
relativement secondaire nous faut
étudier admis que ce vaccin il sera
disponible relativement un coût très
faible il serait totalement inacceptable
que ce vaccin d'un coût élevé et donc
que la question de la nationalisation de
et laboratoires pharmaceutiques le fait
que à laboratoire qui est fait une
découverte ne peut pas l'exploiter à
n'importe quel prix c'est s'est posée de
façon générale il faut espérer que ça se
posera pas dans le cas présent et que le
laboratoire qui va trouver le mettra
gratuitement à la disposition de
l'humanité
merci un beau coup henri interdit n'a
qu'à vous êtes animateur des économistes
atterrés mercier mans